all right let's give away some
memberships last week I mentioned that
an anonymous longtime viewer of the show
reached out to me and said David I want
to help the show grow and I want to help
our children so I am offering a free
membership a one-year membership to one
high school or college student I said
that sounds really great let's have
anybody who is a high school or college
student who wants a free membership
email me and i will read through the
letters about what independent media in
the david pakman show mean to them and i
will pick one person to be the winner
after I announced this this anonymous
viewer got back in touch and said you
know David I'm getting the sense there's
going to be a lot of people interested
in this so i am going to up the ante and
i'm going to donate an additional two
memberships totaling three free
memberships for high school or college
students I received around 75 or 80
letters and I have chosen three
individuals who are going to be
receiving free one-year membership the
first letter is from Troy Albert Schultz
let's take a look at what he had to say
David my name is Troy Albert Schultz I'm
a high school sophomore from thurston
county washington I've been a fan of
your show for nearly three years now
your show helped piqued my interest in
politics and interest that's evolved
over time into something of a hobby of
mine the sad truth is there aren't many
ways one can make the often convoluted
world of politics appeal to your average
teenager the majority of my classmates
have little in the way of knowledge when
it comes to the nuances of the modern
socio-political situation that we live
in many get what views they do have from
parents often without fully
understanding their implications very
very good insight for a while I wasn't
unlike them my parents are staunch
conservatives and evangelicals while
many of my friends more or less repeated
what they saw in the news media your
show was an eye-opening experience for
me helping to broaden and define my
worldview it's helped me better
understand that you often have to look
beyond what the mainstream media reports
I'm proud to say I've become a supporter
of alternative news media thanks to your
show and Troy is also more progressive
Troy you have won a one-year David
Pakman show membership membership number
two
goes to Alexandra Ivanova Ivanova not
exactly sure how it's pronounced who
wrote David I'm an incoming freshman at
the University of California Los Angeles
studying biology I've been watching the
show since about my freshman year of
high school I was hospitalized that year
and being out of school for so long made
me feel so out of touch with what was
going on in the world and I realized how
much I relied on school school to feed
me news wanting to seek out news on my
own I began getting much more invested
in world news and politics and that's
really how I stumbled upon the show
while I'm not majoring in political
science i am heavily invested in
interested in the field and hope to
explore it some more in college I've
been doing mock trial for the last four
years Alexandra going on to say while I
try to get my news from various sources
through the internet and through press
the david pakman show is generally my
go-to source when I want to keep up with
what's happening in the world going on
to say that regardless of whether she
gets the membership or not she is saying
thank you for everything and for
continuing the show after all these
years it means a lot to Alexandra
Ivanova who now is the proud owner can
you own something that's intangible I
guess you can you can own a patented
that's basically just an idea Alexandra
Ivanova the proud owner of a one-year
david pakman show member membership and
lastly today this is a difficult name
for me to say the last free membership
goes to Kenan back [ __ ] I believe is
how this is pronounced let's put
Keenan's letter up on the screen David
my name is keenan backer and i'm a
freshman studying cellular and molecular
biology at the university of south
florida i have been a subscriber to the
david pakman show youtube channel for
two years ever since i saw your
interview with Scott lively since I've
come into contact with the david pakman
show I've invested more time into truly
understanding political affairs within
contemporary events and foregone history
the david pakman show means a lot to me
in the context of my political education
watching the david pakman show launched
this momentum of yearning for political
involvement and in
formative news the david pakman show has
also taught me to be more vigilant in
keeping up with the news and how
important it is to truly understand each
news event adequately and in an unbiased
manner ending his letter by saying he
has always wanted to be a member of the
david pakman show and would be ecstatic
to receive the free membership well
Keenan mark yourself down as ecstatic
because you also are the recipient of a
free David Pakman show membership we
will email all three of you later today
keep an eye out for that congratulations
and a big thank you to our anonymous
viewer who has donated these three
memberships